authentique car j'appartiens à la race
de ceux qui restent à l'écart
radicalement opposées sensationnel à la
une à l'appel dont pique nique nique ta
mère les yeux ouverts tout cas à londres
comme à l'envers c'est clair
en chine c'est bien toi
affrontements entre forces de l'ordre et
mène
un vrai problème avec le jeune de
banlieue qui sentent rejetés kampot
novotech se répète pas un peu plus
judicieux
j'ai rarement seule ambition plus demain
quoi qu'il advienne nous appartient la
puissance pour nos mains alors ils sont
débordés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
taylor et tmc
qu'est-ce que ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du coup
cette somme ni baby